Today we will talk about Meta-Reasoning.
Meta-Reasoning is thinking about
thinking, knowledge about knowledge.
In this case,
the agent does not reasoning about
something outside in the world.
Instead, the agent is
reasoning about itself, but
its own knowledge,
its own reasoning, its own learning.
As an example, I can ask you what is
President Obama's telephone number?
I'm sure that all of you can
immediately tell me, you don't know.
But how do you know,
that you don't know?
We test a little bit about
meta-reasoning when we were talking
about learning by correcting mistakes.
There, we were interested in
errors in the knowledge base.
In journal, errors can also be
in reasoning or in learning.
We'll start today by talking
about mistakes in reasoning and
learning, in addition to
mistakes in knowledge.
Then we'll talk about knowledge gaps,
not just errors in the knowledge, but
when some knowledge is actually missing.
Then we'll talk about a very
journal meta-cognitive skill,
which leads to strategy selection and
integration.
And this class, we have talked about
a large number of methods, but
we haven't yet talked about how
an intelligent agents can put
multiple methods together to
address a complex problem.
Then we'll discuss meta-meta-reasoning.
Or meta-meta-meta-reasoning,
how far can we go?
Finally, we'll discuss an example
of meta-reasoning election
that is sometimes called
goal-based autonomy.